hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book 2 chapter 16 of his meditations
Marcus Aurelius is going to talk about
how it is that the human being or as
he's going to put it here the human soul
the soul of the human being damages or
injures or to use another translation
degrades itself and he sets out five
main ways this is not a comprehensive
list but five main ways in which this
happens and we want to be really
attentive to the language that he's
using because if we pay close attention
to it there's a lot going on here in
these passages so injuring itself who
bridge
is the verb for hubris
showing hubris which typically we tend
to associate with like pridefulness or
some sort of uh attempt to dominate
other people and it does include that in
ancient Greek but it also includes the
sense of injuring of doing harm to
another or in this case its very own
self a disregard for what's actually
good and a willingness to allow damage
to occur so the human soul is damaging
itself when it falls into these five
problematic and to some degree
overlapping or interconnected
attitudes comportments ways of doing
things so the first one which he talks
about at a little bit more length than
the others is translated here as when it
does its best right now that's an
interesting way of talking about it the
Greek is actually hoyon epayote and for
anybody who's read stoic philosophy
particularly Epictetus this epitheote is
really quite striking because that's the
realm of what is up to us it's part of
what's often called the dichotomy of
control which we know Marcus is quite
familiar with because he's red Epictetus
and mentions him so when it's up to the
soul or insofar as it's up to the soul
what does the soul do that's problematic
well here we get to this this quite Rich
language it becomes like an abscess
apostema
literally a thing that's like pulling
apart distancing itself so like when
your skin breaks and gets infected and
starts oozing and stuff like that
that's what the soul sometimes can be
like or like some sort of growth and it
could be translated as a detached growth
could be translated equally well as a
cancer so anything from say a skin tag
all the way through boils to actual
cancer tumors now how does a soul become
like that because it does that in
relation to the world the cosmos the
universe and you might say well that's
kind of weird how is a person sometimes
we say that person's like a boil on the
face of humanity or something along
those lines and what we mean is they
become noxious they don't fit in with
the rest of things they're taking too
much for themselves and so he he says to
be disgruntled at anything and that just
gruntled is a word that sometimes
translates
um
anger or irritation uh literally it's
it's being of a bad Spirit about things
so being of a bad spirit and anything
that happens he says is a kind of
secession from nature from foosis from
the nature of things and the universe
that we're a part of and he says which
comprises the nature or Natures of all
things all the things that are in
existence all the things that we
encounter so when we make too much of
ourselves in we often think oh I'm like
carving out my own space everyone's got
to look out for number one we're
actually damaging ourself because we
according to Marcus are connected with
the rest of the universe that we're
trying to you know take more than our
fair share from
uh the second one he says when it turns
away from apostrafe right it it you know
turns its back as one translation but it
could just be it distance itself from uh
from who from from other people and
brings opposition anantia ferrata it it
brings things that are opposed right
that might be noxious in order to injure
host blabsusa so it's trying to injure
other people not itself right uh sets
out to do harm is another way of
translating this
and then Marcus says like The Souls of
the angry people uh Oregon
those who are in the process of being
and expressing their anger what do angry
people do well they do in fact distance
themselves from others they do in fact
bring opposition they do in fact try to
hurt to injure to insult other people
and Marcus is saying once again
when you do that you're not just
injuring somebody else you are damaging
your own self by doing this the third
one is relatively short when it's
overcome by Pleasure or by pain but I
think it is kind of interesting to note
here
so pleasure being overcome by Hayden or
pain ponos in this case ponu because
it's in the in the uh dative
um so pleasure Hayden that's very
straightforward right there's there's a
a lot of opportunities for us to see
something pleasant know that we
shouldn't pursue it we shouldn't take it
we shouldn't prioritize it but we do
anyway and that that means we're
overcome with it and this could be
everything from you know an illicit
Affair to having a midnight snack when
we're not supposed to have a midnight
snack and everything in between right
pain here is not Lupe which is usually
the the opposed thing to pleasure this
psychological State it's ponos which
also translates as toil now in ancient
philosophy uh Pleasure and Pain the Pain
part is sometimes translated by Lupe
sometimes by ponos depending on which
philosopher we're looking at very common
among the cynics to talk about uh pain
as as toil right but it's also something
they take on what does it mean to be
overcome by toil or pain in that respect
it means that something is difficult
difficult to Bear difficult to do maybe
demanding upon us and we don't do it we
Retreat from it we try to get away from
it why would that be injuring the soul
well because the soul
isn't supposed to be guided merely by
Pleasure and Pain it's supposed to go
through those it's fine to enjoy
pleasure it's okay to endure pain right
it's actually good to do so uh but those
shouldn't be the primary motivators and
so that that's a problem especially when
it becomes a habit
the fourth one is particularly
interesting when it puts on a mask now
the Greek for that is uh connected to a
term that you probably recognize from a
somewhat different context
hi right so we get the word hypocrisy
and hypocrite from this and that
originally means somebody who either is
an actor
or somebody who is behaving like an
actor somebody who is as we say putting
on errors in this case putting out a
mask because in ancient times a lot of
the comedy and tragedy you actually had
a mask that you put on so in ordinary
life you're putting on a mask when
you're playing somebody else you're
pretending to be something that you're
not and this involves doing or saying so
both action and words what something
fake uh uh epiplastos behaving in a fake
way an inauthentic way translated here
as artificial is another good way or
something that's false now this is a
very interesting term because literally
in the Greek it's not so much false or
lying uh pseudes but rather not true
on meaning not or taking something away
alethos and this is an adverb describing
how somebody behaves so behaving in we
could say an inauthentic in a insincere
a non-truthful way right false
encompasses it but it's not the kind of
falsity of like oh I made a mistake with
numbers or something like that you are
portraying yourself as something other
than you really are in your actions and
your words and your sentiments and your
attitudes and again Marcus thinks that
by doing so this is damaging to the
human being the the soul of the human
being
and then finally we have this very
interesting one when it allows its
action and impulse to be without a
purpose to be random and disconnected so
this kind of the random and disconnected
Harkens back to the first one right
because if you're behaving as if you are
a totally independent being and what you
do has no connection to the rest of the
universe well that can be this
disconnected literally like severed from
other things or random now that that
Randomness has to do with the not having
some sort of purpose or goal or end in
mind when you're doing things or I think
it could also be having too many of them
and like just well I'm doing this now
I'm doing this now I'm focused over here
right people who don't have a clear set
of priorities
so action Praxis right that's the things
that we do now here's where it gets
really interesting impulse so
ume in Greek is the stoic term for
impulse now horme does mean impulse like
a directionality towards something you
know moving towards something but it
also means choice
so our actions and the things driving us
and our choices about that the way in
which we actually decide the way in
which we prioritize right that is uh
something we have to pay attention to so
without a purpose there's two different
words that are used here scope is scopos
is a literally something you're sighting
in on like when you're you know shooting
an arrow at the Target you have a scopos
and that's to hit the target if you're
shooting an arrow to hit an anime
Soldier well your target is maybe their
chest or if you're a really good shot
you know their eyeball or something
along those lines and actions can be
purposive or they could be purposeless
and you know we do have some
we could say if they have purposes
they're very trivial ones you know
walking down the street whistling oh why
are you whistling I don't know I'm just
whistling a song that got stuck in my
head you know oh there must be some
Grand purpose no probably not right but
the other things that we do we should
order them so that they're actually
achieving something the other word that
gets used in this passage is Telos and
goal the thing that we're striving for
and scopos and Telos kind of go hand in
hand here and Marcus is going to tell us
that
um even the smallest things ought to be
directed to a goal it doesn't mean that
the goal is all that we focus on but you
know that's that's some good guidance
and then he says the goal for us us
human beings rational beings the kind of
beings that we are is to follow the rule
and law of the most ancient of
communities and States now what is that
does he mean like well we should all be
Romans no because the Romans aren't the
most ancient Saints maybe we should all
be Sumerians no because that's not what
he has in mind the most ancient of
communities and states is the stoic
Commonwealth of gods and good human
beings human beings that are actually
living out their nature that are not
allowing themselves to turn into a tumor
on the world right so we have the
possibility of participating according
to to Marcus not only in nature itself
but even in this nationally ordered
Commonwealth of higher beings that
include ourselves if we're not allowing
our soul to injure itself so these are
some really important things to keep in
mind don't be a tumor don't act like the
angry people don't let yourself be
overcome by Pleasure and Pain don't be a
hypocrite you know an actor and make
sure that you've got some sort of
purpose good purpose legitimate purpose
to the things that you're actually doing
and thereby you'll avoid damaging your
soul